hello calculator fancy is a bit of an
unusual one today I have been sent this
in by an amateur calculator appreciator
Robert in the United States of America
found this in his parents basement
they are Robert I bet you didn't think
when you pull this out and dusted it off
that one day you'd see it here I mean
this is Centre Court the MP Center of
the calculator appreciating well it just
goes to show you everyone at home with
your little calculator collections that
one day all your calculator dreams can
come true okay so here we have the Casio
with an unexpected extra that's slightly
more threatening than I like my
calculators to be but you can see it has
got two color printing which is two more
colors than most now just very quickly
I'm aware this is officially a historic
calculator because it's quite an old one
that's been sent in and some of you will
be concerned that while it is still in
its original box it's not mint in its
original box has been damaged here like
some kind of heavy blow to the top
there's some scuffing around the bottom
it is not museum quality there's some
marks on here very disappointing and
from a proper collecting point of view
we don't know the history of this capita
it's got no provenance
I mean there's no chain that shows where
this came from so I'm well aware this is
not up to the standards you'd expect but
for a bit of fun I'm prepared to pop it
open and have a closer look and here we
go like this should slide out and oh
okay so here we have some paper for
printing that's going to be handy here
we've got some of these with a yellowing
tape on them to hold maybe it was yellow
to start with now for the UK collector
it's a little inconvenient that the us
adapters are 120 volts or freedom
voltage as it's commonly referred to but
as a purist I'm not going to swap that
out for in a replacement one I want to
keep the proper one the official
standard practice is to get an adapter
to adapt the adapter to your local
situation so you need to get an adapter
adapter or adapter squared as we call it
little joke there from the calculator
community okay getting down to the
calculator itself we have here we go
look at
at so it's got a kind of dust cover
there so there's in a place with lots
debris that might land on it you can
keep it carefully case under there at a
moment's notice it's got the full
instructions look at that and warranty
now the HR 100 is well known for having
the largest broadsheet instruction
manual in the business look at that so
the box has got quite a nice look to it
now as previously discussed we can't use
the u.s. adapter straight away and so
we're going to have to put some
batteries in the back of this bad boy
okay so it takes four double A batteries
batteries please for double A's thank
you very much now we'll pop one in there
it's always very important to put your
batteries in facing the right way around
otherwise you will your calculator can
catch on fire
it can explode or even worse you might
get the wrong answer to one of your
calculations I'm afraid I'm gonna have
to give you a Gore warning look away if
you don't like horrific medical sites
because I've actually cut my finger
opening up this cap you can see look
look at that
it's barely attached anymore I've cut my
digit while trying to get into you some
more digits I mean that that's just the
risks I accept when you're opening
calculators at this kind of level okay
we just pop that back on there and now
the batteries are in we will fire this
thing up to on all right so this is just
basic calculator mode so let's do we'll
do the standard divide by zero one
divided by zero equals and a tiny tiny
error over there doesn't make a big deal
of it that's quite nice and we'll do a
quick division precision is that clear
one oh it's locked
clear I have a weekly okay let's do 1
divided by 9 equals that's alliance
times 9 equals so you can see they're
not entirely accurate which is quite
good if you're trying to fudge the books
to have a little bit of wiggle room in
your calculations and finally you got
feed over here so obviously when you're
doing your accounts you'll be working
around the clock if you do have to go
and get some substance you can just hit
feed Oh oh my goodness
oh so no feed is for the printer and you
know what that is why we're here we want
to see the printing in action let's load
up the paper just tidy up the edge there
okay so the paper goes obviously on the
back here so we'll shove it in there and
then hit feed come on take it here we go
okay now we're ready to do some
calculations while it prints so if I do
one plus I've committed the one to the
paper now no going back two plus four
plus eight plus sixteen you can see as
I'm adding these numbers on they're all
being printed up there we're up to 62
plus a 124 plus 248 and now if we want
to get the grand total you hit star and
there is print at the bottom and if we
feed that up you can see there's my
whole calculation and I know what you
can you can then cut that off there if
you want to do a calculation and send it
to someone else incredibly convenient a
little souvenir
send it off everyone else can enjoy it
okay so let's do some tests while we're
printing 1/0 equals o when they I see
it's done a full line you can see that
it's not happy it's done no no no no no
clear that if I do 1 divided by super
zero so double zero and it goes and
still note very very unhappy with that
let's clear that out
okay let's try seeing how it does with
undoing division so 1/9 equals and so
there we've got very loads of ones very
good now we'll multiply that by 9 equals
no not quite that's very disappointing
what is this right so very knowingly it
tries to do it and it didn't get back to
one so then this is now a little
monument to it
you can keep that right you can you can
be like look what you've done that is
very disappointing I'm very upset with
you very rarely can you show a
calculator what it's done incorrectly
like that now one of the great things
about a printing calculator if you're
doing a calculation like you put in
fifty eight thousand and you add eight
right and then you want to get the grand
total for that once it's printed out you
can feed it all the way through and
normally you've got to pick the
calculator up and move it around because
it's a printing calculator nothing has
to go anywhere and you can still turn
the answer around
so very quickly we'll just check a bit
the display is we've got one two three
four five six seven eight nine digits 10
11 12 no 13 hits an error at 13 but it
does display big 12 digit that's quite
nice and if you want if you want you
want to keep a reminder of just how many
digits you've got of course you can
print that out and then you want in fact
on there more than 12 things on the
display because you've got all the nice
fancy curly commas look at those good
typography you've got an overly sized
decimal point as a space and a plus I
mean that that is a good display so
there you are the Casio unexpected extra
twelve digits to color printing big
display printing calculator model number
HR - 1 0 0 te plus negative w adapter
included now obviously I'm just doing
this is a bit of an exhibition piece
it's a bit of fun for the fans at home I
can't give it a proper score so they are
Robert thank you very much for sending
this in and thank you for being an
inspiration to everyone else getting
into the calculator game who would have
thought that a calculator you found in
the basement in the United States that
would one day end up here at the South
Surrey and associated regions calculator
appreciation Society for professionals
and amateurs